y llegamos al segmento de nuestro
invitado del día en este caso es una
invitada para hablar y seguir con lo que
estábamos comentando con ross a estas
elecciones presidenciales francesas que
recordemos este próximo domingo 10 de
abril es la primera vuelta el candidato
presidente manuel macrón lidera las
encuestas pero todo indica que de todas
formas va a pasar a un balotaje con el
que que en segundo lugar y para ello
entonces nos acompaña en nuestro estudio
es venir richard analista experta en
relaciones internacionales docente
investigadora de la universidad
externado de colombia además ya amiga de
la casa como ésta se oyen gracias por
estar con nosotros buena mañana de
viernes muchas gracias por la invitación
pues vamos a empezar entonces hablando o
rosa tiene la primera pregunta para hoy
in
entonces quería preguntarle bueno quería
empezar con una cuestión que aprendimos
ayer o antes de ayer y es que por
ejemplo uno de los principales medios de
comunicación una de las principales
televisiones hablamos de tf1 de francia
no va a dedicar una gran noche electoral
a analizar los resultados de la primera
vuelta de estas presidenciales sino que
va a hacer un programa de una hora y
después va a redifundir una comedia
francesa por enésima vez no es esto una
anécdota o es un síntoma de este
desinterés que se atribuye a estas
elecciones francesas pues yo creo que sí
es sintomático ustedes lo han mostrado
la mayoría de los franceses no están
tanto preocupados por la campaña
presidencial efectivamente stefan digo
que va a pasar la película le visitaba
entonces un gran éxito comercial
eso significa que finalmente en qué
escenario estamos hay mucha atención en
francia hay mucha preocupación estamos
en un escenario de guerra el precio de
la gasolina está por las nubes la gente
se está preguntando qué va a pasar con
los precios también de los alimentos
entonces hay una preocupación por el
cotidiano el diario vivir y no hay tanta
pasión digamos que se proyecta en esta
campaña electoral además el presidente
de manuel marco también ha contribuido
en estudio ambiente diciendo bueno en
este momento yo soy más presidente que
candidato quiero gobernar hasta el
último cuarto de hora porque el
escenario internacional lo requiere
entonces yo creo que es mitad
estratégico y mitad coyuntural pero en
todo caso no hay mucha pasión digamos en
esta campaña es un hecho pero esta
preocupación por esta dificultad no
desde este momento no desencadenar una
preocupación por quién va a gobernar el
país en los próximos cinco años yo creo
que los franceses ya tienen claro que
manuel mccomb va a ser reelegido y de
hecho es la gran preocupación del mismo
presidente él dice no podemos dejar de
ir a votar porque la gente piensa que ya
voy a estar reelegido de manera contiene
mucho miedo a los extremos que como lo
mostraban los sondeos están subiendo
mientras la izquierda y la derecha
tradicional se están debilitando así que
manuel más quiere que la gente vaya a
votar pero digamos que no está está
haciendo una campaña haciendo política y
más que todo política exterior claro
también es jenny y no bajará el agua
para que sus seguidores evidentemente
voten por él y pues si tenga asegurada
está segunda presidencia esto según
estos segundos o cuatro años más pero le
quiero preguntar a usted está hablando
también del contexto internacional
evidentemente de la guerra que afecta
también a europa con toda esta cuestión
del combustible de la energía incluso
están los líderes europeos reunidos en
bruselas viendo a ver cómo hacer para ya
no depender más de los hidrocarburos de
rusia como afectado todo este conflicto
a la campaña presidencial
interna digamos de todos los candidatos
y enfocándonos también en el candidato
presidente emmanuel macro pero pero
también hablamos de los otros este
contexto internacional sin duda ha
fortalecido a emanuel mccoy como
presidente y como candidato presidente
porque él se ha dedicado a actuar y
digamos que eso le da le ha dado mucha
visibilidad a los otros candidatos se
han visto un poquito perjudicados por
dos razones primero porque todavía no
pueden incidir en la política
internacional y segundo porque manuel
macon dijo que no iba a ser debates
antes de la primera ronda porque se
tenía que dedicar a gobernar entonces
esta campaña electoral digamos que está
un poco invisibilizada por este contexto
internacional
y en digamos dentro de francia no uno de
los temas recurrentes de debate público
como veíamos aquí con las distintas
noticias que hemos seleccionado es pues
la gestión migratoria también de las
religiones y muy particularmente del
islam entonces al mismo tiempo se se ha
dado mucho protagonismo tal y como
señalaba un análisis de liberación de
este mismo año a personajes que
defienden posturas de extrema derecha y
que posteriormente se han presentado las
elecciones como es el caso de eric se
more entonces porque particularmente
dentro de de francia se da tanta
importancia a este tipo de cuestiones
porque hace décadas existe una atención
sobre esta cuestión migratoria y digamos
que la extrema derecha se ha acaparado
del tema monopoliza el tema del islam
diciendo finalmente todos nuestros
problemas viene de estas poblaciones
inmigrantes que tenemos en nuestro
territorio que muchas veces son
inmigrantes de segunda generación es
decir que son franceses pero están
señalados como franceses de segunda zona
digamos eric samur es esta persona que
está hablando sobre este tema de
migración que ha propuesto devolver un
millón de personas sobre 5 años en su
país de origen y digamos que eso es lo
que permite tener visibilidad electoral
hay una cierta atención en francia hay
un disgusto entre franceses digamos
originarios y franceses de segunda zona
y la extrema derecha está creciendo
desde hace 20 30 40 años sobre este
terreno electoral entonces es una
retórica que no van a abandonar porque
es esencialmente lo que les da los votos
ahora también yo ni le quiero preguntar
qué va a pasar con extrema izquierda y
cómo se podría catalogar realmente sin
objetivos al presidente de manuel macrón
porque muchos dicen que es
una persona pues pintada de centro pero
que va más a la derecha realmente que es
donde está ubicado el presidente macro
en esto y qué pasa con extrema izquierda
bueno él manuel manjón se vende de
centro y de hecho así ha ganado la
presidencia la última vez pero él manuel
también estaba jugando a lo que hizo
también todos los presidentes antes de
él es fortalecer las y los extremos
tanto extremo derecha como extrema
izquierda para las fuerzas centristas
que le podría competir digamos en
primera vuelta el resultado eso tenemos
una extrema derecha que entre dos
candidatos como la del 30 por ciento de
los votos tenemos una extrema izquierda
a 15% tenemos que manuel ma con el
centro muy cómodo con sus casi 30 por
ciento pero tenemos una izquierda
tradicional menos del 10% y una derecha
también tradicional a menos del 10 por
ciento entonces emanuel mccone si no es
de centro digamos ideológicamente es más
de centroderecha pero lo que él hace es
que ocupa esta posición para debilitar
las fuerzas que lo podrían digamos
competir en el centro y por eso pues ha
utilizado esta estrategia de fortalecer
tanto la extrema derecha como la extrema
izquierda y a lo largo no desde que en
que nato de manuel macro no hemos visto
en las calles francesas muchísimo
descontento que se ha expresado tanto en
los chalecos amarillos como protestas
estudiantiles de médicos del personal
educativo y hasta pues todas las
personas que han protestado contra la
reforma de las pensiones finalmente
quien ha acabado capitalizando este
descontento en francia- tonto extrema
derecha como la extrema izquierda es por
eso que ellos se venden como el 'voto
útil' diciendo si ustedes no están de
acuerdo con las políticas de mayo es el
voto útil es el voto de imagen o es el
voto de tziolis - o sonic menor son si
quiere vender como el voto y chile en la
izquierda diciendo miren todas las
fuerzas de izquierdas están muy
divididas pero yo soy la única opción a
la izquierda de pasar en segunda ronda
entonces si realmente quieren una
alternativa a emanuel bach que hay que
votar menos o más que cualquier otro
candidato recordamos sin embargo que
manuel ma cuando la detenido fácil desde
su llegada al poder le ataca los
atentados los chalecos amarillos el coi
y ahora la guerra en ucrania